I thought if I commend where's a thin little man with bowlegs as a hook nose in
the civilian world,
he had been viewed as of new accounts,
are socially awkward laser with little to redeem himself,
I think joined the Nazi party.
However,
his unquestioning commitment to orders coupled with his need for ruthless
efficiency,
allowing him to carve out of Korea though would see him go down as one of the
greatest mass murderers in human history and this week's biographics.
We trace the life,
the crimes and the death of ad off Eichmann.
I don't fall through.
Eichmann was born and Zuellig and Germany on march the 19th 1906 do bookkeeper.
I don't have call Eichmann and his wife Maria,
the oldest of five children,
young adults was a nervous,
shy child with few friends.
When he was seven years old,
his father moved to Lynn's to take a job as a commercial manager for the city's
electrical provider with the rest of the family.
Following a year later in Lynn's out of attended the kinds of friends,
Joseph Secondary School,
the same school that ad off hitting a rigid ended in the 1890s he remains an
aloof and lonely child and his parents worried about his lack of social skills.
His dark complexion and distinctive knows and Dheas led to his school mates
teasing him with a nickname deck,
Klein Judah,
or the little Jew.
I don't prove to be a mediocre student at best.
By the time he became a teenager,
he had a reputation as being difficult and moody with his father having written
him off as a no hoper with little promise,
a furthering an education.
He quit school at the age of 15 and has began to train as a mechanic.
That's this to you proved to be a failure after too frustrating years.
He gave up on this career and took a job as a sales agent for a mining company.
This job also lasted for two years.
Afterwards.
She became a district agents for an all company by the age of 25 Eichmann was a
Sullen,
withdrawn,
and socially and apps are the four man who could still be mistaken for a Jew.
He had a stable but uninspiring job that saw him working around Upper Austria in
Salzburg in 1932 despite having never shown any interest in political affairs,
he joins the National Socialist Party.
His association with the Party began at the urging of a friend by the name of
[inaudible] Bruner,
who was a party official
for Eichmann the party.
We'd give them an opportunity to belong to a group and to advance his station in
life more than anything.
He wanted to be somebody and wanted to prove to the world that he had value as
an individual.
In November of 1932 he was accepted into the ranks of the SS with his duties
involving forming part of the protection squad for speakers at party rallies as
well as gardening the party headquarters that lense at the same.
He was still working for the oil company a few weeks after Hitler became
chancellor of Germany in January of 1933 I commend lost his job.
Do you have to staff cut backs?
He immediately applied for active assets duty in Germany.
This was accepted them as he proved to be a diligent follower of orders rising
to the rank of shore for Yara in just a few months.
In November of 1933 he was appointed to the administrative staff of the dot
Hsiao concentration camp at shall I Cummins job was to keep a detailed catalog
of all the items that were being confiscated from incoming Jewish prisoners.
He did his job well,
but found it to be exceedingly boring.
Around this time,
you began to set his mind to studying and inculcating the basic principles of
Nazi-ism in something I bought.
He had come to believe.
He says if they had told me that my own father was a traitor and I had to kill
him,
I'd have done it in under CMT breakouts of is monotonous routine at Dap Shao in
1934 I couldn't apply to join the SD,
which was the security service of the SS.
His application was successful and he was transferred to the Nazi party head
office in Berlin.
He was quickly promoted to the rank of hub shit Fiora.
I come in this job boys now to investigate and create reports on the activities
of Jewish organizations in Germany.
He threw himself into the work learning the basics of the Hebrew language and
establishing himself as the Nazi party expert on the culture and the history of
the Jews.
Around this time,
the perennially shy Eichmann met and fell in love with Veronica label after the
required vetting to ensure that she had no Jewish heritage.
The couple were married on March the 21st 1935 that would go on to have four
sons in 1937 like man who now held the rank of ss wound,
a storm for ra or second left tenants with sends on an important mission to the
British mandate of Palestine along with his superior officer.
He was there to investigate the feasibility of German Jews being forcibly made
to migrate to Palestine,
but the mission,
it never got off the grounds with the British refusing them entry into the
country and the week of the annexation of Austria.
I can move to Vienna with the job of organizing the local assets that his
efficiency in doing so earns him another promotion.
This time to the rank of SS obersturmfuhrer run or fast left tenants.
He was also selected to initiate the Central Office for Jewish emigration whose
express purpose was to force it.
The expulsion of all Jews from Austria
Eichmann throw himself into his new role with an unusual zeal.
Within eight months.
He had stripped the vast majority of Jews in the country of all their lands and
their possessions and forced to 45,000 to leave.
I'm going to see a further 150,000 something disappeared.
His efficiency,
failure,
it greatly impressed to superiors.
The invasion,
Poland on September the first 1939 and the subsequent outbreak of war let's
policy towards the Jews changed.
No longer would they be encouraged to leave Germany from now on.
They would be forcibly deported.
Jews were to be herded together and sent it to concentration camps situated in
newly acquired parts of the Reich.
In October of 1939 I it was posted to Berlin where he works directly under
Gestapo chief Heinrich and Miller in establishing the nationwide central office
for Jewish emigration.
His first job was the clear specified areas of Poland's of juice.
At the same time,
he continued his past projects of ridding his beloved Vienna of the Jewish
problem.
He selected Nipsco when the far north of Poland as the site for a transit camp.
Whether you expelled Jews would be gathered before sending them to the harsh
Russian wilderness in order to fend for themselves.
Meanwhile,
ethnic Jews were being moved into the areas of Poland's where the Jews had been
evicted on December the 19th 1939 I then received,
yes,
another promotion.
He was now the overall coordinator of Jewish affairs and evacuation for the
entire German Reich,
all deportations to camps in Poland when now under his ultimate control,
many at thousands of Jews were also being sent to an area in the east of
Poland's,
known as the general governments.
I come in immediately dropped plans to send 600,000 Jews into the general
government,
but these plans were pushed back due to complaints by authorities in the east
who will worry that too many Jews would ruin the economy and the end,
some 63,000 people were relocated to the area with many of them dying and
transit all over occupied Europe.
Jews were crowded into ghettos as they waited to be sent away.
The conditions in the ghettos.
They were appalling and as many people died before they ever step foot on a
train carriage.
In 1940 Eichmann released a plan's resettle a million people every year and
Madagascar.
His plan had relied on the Luftwaffe,
a conquering the British and the battle of Britain,
which would have enabled the Germans do take control if the skies over the
Atlantic.
When this failed to happen,
the plans for operation Madagascar,
they were shelved in definitely,
and September of 1941 Oakland was called to a meeting with the head of the SD
Reinhardt Heidrich.
In this meeting,
he was informed that the fear had ordered that all Jews in countries occupied by
Germany were to be put to death.
The timeline for this was to swing into action off to the conquest of the Soviet
Union.
However,
the entry of the United States since the war following the Japanese attack on
Pearl Harbor forced to rethink if this is the extermination of the Jews,
was to be given maximum priority.
In 1942 hydrate calls a meeting of the major players in the Nazi Organization of
[inaudible] on the outskirts of Berlin.
It was during this meeting that's an official policy of Jewish genocide was laid
out.
Heidrick calls it the final solution to the Jewish question.
I had prepared for this by creating lists of the numbers of Jews in each country
who had to be exterminated.
Heidrick then appointed in his right hand man and man responsible for
coordinating all of the trains that would be used to carry Jews to Polish
concentration camps as a result of the constant supply of human fodder that
Eichmann was responsible for the death camps that outfits Sta.
How Treblinka and book involved became 24 hour killing machines.
I can funnels Jews and Gypsies from Austria,
Holland,
France,
the Baltic states and Yugoslavia do that slaughter often.
They were sent first to Warsaw and other ghettos in Poland for resettlement for
the wrist and a gross example of distorted perception.
I can rate the following about his work jewelry.
It was grateful for the chance they gave it to learn community life at the
ghetto.
It made an excellent school for the future in Israel.
Basically,
most Jews feel well and happy and that ghetto life.
As the months passed,
the demands placed on [inaudible] and to speed up the killing machine increased.
He was responsible for supplying victims to a total of 164 camps spread
throughout Eastern Europe and attempts to make the process more efficient.
He oversaw the enlargement of the Dev trains still.
He gave no thought to supplying those who were crammed into the carriages for
weeks on end with food or water and many of them died on the way I Cummins.
Organizational ability was also employed to improve the efficiency of the actual
killing process.
He designs the huge windowless rooms and suggested that they be disguised as
shower units.
In order to allay panic.
He also pushed for the replacements of the relatively inefficient carbon
monoxide gas with the cyanide based insecticide.
It's like plumbing B.
We can get an insight into Eichmann's ruthless efficiency by an incident which
occurred during a roundup of Jews in Paris in 1942 7,000 people were rounded up
4,051 of them being children.
However,
the city powers objected to the deportation and has managed to secure talks with
Aikman.
The Jews were holed up in a warehouse without food or water.
For six days.
I come and stare down the French officials insisting that every single Jew had
to be sent east to their deaths.
In 1944 Eichmann was transferred to Hungary,
which had recently been overrun by the Nazis.
He was tasked with fast tracking the transportation of Hungarian Jews to death
camps,
something that he did with ruthless efficiency.
In just a few months he had condemns more than 400,000 of them.
Bye Ali and 1945 it was obvious to many in the Nazi hierarchy for the game was
up with the Russians coming at them from one side and the allies closing in from
the other.
The priority for many became personal survival.
Reinhard Heidrick decided that the time had come to put an end to the mass
extermination of the Jews and set about destroying any evidence of the crimes
against humanity.
That had been,
when I come in,
heard about this,
he was not happy.
He decided of his own volition to continue and to even speed up the killings.
But finally,
even he saw the writing on the wall,
his biggest fear seem to be that he would be sent out to the front lines to
fight the Russian.
This of the Americans in March with the Russians pouring into a hungry,
he fled to Australia where he tried to get his old friend and it's Talton Bruna
to help him evade capture by the allies.
But at the ends of his involvements that Eichmann had had with the Jewish
slaughter had made him dangerous man to associate with,
and it's Colton Brennan who was trying to save his own skin once,
had nothing to do with him.
Surely thereafter,
Eichmann was captured by the U s army having given a false name.
He was transferred between several POW camps.
He was part of a work detail.
Then charm and Germany.
When he escaped,
he managed to secure new identity papers and took on the identity of auto
Henning and he relocated to loon bag heath in Lower Saxony.
Eliza phones work in the forestry sector.
Other members of the Nazi hierarchy were not as fortunate as I come in in their
attendance to evade justice.
Many of them ended up at the Nuremberg war trials where they gave detailed
evidence about the role that I came in and played and the systematic planning
and extermination of the Jews.
As a result of this,
he became one of the most sought after Nazi war criminals in 1950 Eichmann
relocated to Italy.
Yeah.
He received the assistance of Allahu doll,
a Roman Catholic bishop.
He was a Nazi sympathizer and had already helps many Nazis get out of Europe.
Huddle all helps Eichmann obtain a humanitarian passport from the International
Committee of the Red Cross along with fake identification and landing permits
for Argentina.
We think these documents,
he was able to secure an international passport from the Red Cross.
He now had everything you needed to sail for South America.
He departed from Genoa on June the 17th 1950 and arrived in Buenos Aires on July
the 14th
pull the next two years under the name of Ricardo Clemens Eichmann.
It worked for a government contractor in to come and province.
After two years,
he felt secure enough to bring over his wife and sons.
They moved to Buenos Aires where I came,
worked in a series of menial jobs before finding employment with Mercedes Benz.
Over the next few years he would employ,
has natural organizational skills to rise to the position of department.
Had beginning in 1956 and Neo Nazi fanatic began interviewing.
I can manage this home with a goal of writing a fawning biography for this
project,
so large and damning collection of tapes,
transcripts and notes were produced.
Meanwhile,
a handful of determined his Nazi hunters.
We're hot on Aikman's trail.
Prominence among them was former concentration camp inmates,
Simon Wiesenthal in 1953 Weisen full that founds a postcard in which a former
Nazi victim had mentioned seeing that pig Eichmann and Buenos Aires.
He passed this information onto the Israeli consulate in Vienna,
the American CIA.
We're also aware of the type of man was in South America.
However,
they were unwilling to act on the information for fear of embarrassing
themselves.
In the postwar years the Americans and employed and number of Nazis do work on
the Manhattan atomic bomb project.
They didn't want to go near anything that would allow that information to leak
to the public.
Meanwhile,
why some full was working with the Israeli intelligence service massage to build
a picture of Eichmann's life in Argentina.
A break in the case came when Eichmann's second oldest son got involved with the
daughter of a Holocaust survivor who had relocated to Argentina.
The why the guns and boost that his father had worked for Hitler and was in fact
the brains behind is the final solution of the Jewish question.
The girl promptly reports and this information back to our father who in turn
informs the Israeli authorities.
Amazon sends an operative to Buenos Aires to confirm I Cummins location and his
identity.
It was now up to Israeli Prime Minister David Ben Gurion to decide whether to
proceed diplomatically or to simply sees Eichmann and bringing back to Israel.
To face the music knowing that the Argentinians had a record of declining
extradition requests involving former Nazis.
Ben Gurion decided to take Eichmann by force.
An eight man team of Mossad operatives were send to Argentina to carry out the
mission.
The operation was carried out on maybe 11th 1960 as Eichmann was walking home
from work to agents,
pretended to be working on a car or was he walks past.
A third agent approached and asked him for a cigarette.
I come in,
I demanded nervously and in that moment all three agents sprang upon him.
One of them,
a black belt in karate delivered a blow to his neck,
which rendered him unconscious.
Eichmann was bundled into a car and taken to a safe house where he was stripped
naked and examiners under his right arm.
There it's the agents found a partially removed to tattoo,
which confirmed that he was a member of the SS on May the 21st day heavily
sedated Eichmann were smuggled out of Argentina on a commercial flight.
It was bound for Israel.
When Prime Minister Ben Gurion announced that the most wanted Nazi and the wells
had been captured.
It caused an international sensation because the Argentinian strongly protested
the manner of the abduction claiming,
but it had been a violation of Argentinian sovereignty then Gloria and replied
that I can had been captured by agents of the Israeli government,
but by individual citizens that the trial of Adolf Eichmann,
it began on April the 11th 1961 in Israel's Beth Hon.
How's if the people 15 charges leveled against him,
including crimes against humanity?
The challenge encompass the view that he was the man in direct control of the
entire Nazi bureaucratic structure,
responsible for the deaths of millions of people before and during the war.
I haven't.
This trial was broadcast live on TV stations around the globe.
After listening to the emotional testimony of Holocaust survivors and others
didn't try to deny the facts.
His soul defense was that he was simply carrying out orders.
He stated that he never did anything great or small without obtaining an
advanced express instructions.
Madoff,
Hitler or any of my superiors.
The trial took 14 at the end of which I commend was convicted on all counts.
The sentence was death by hanging his defense team made and unsuccessful appeal
for clemency,
which was turned down by the new Israeli prime minister.
The execution was carried out on June the first 1962 at Israel's rambler prison.
I couldn't refuse the black codes that was offered to him on the gallows.
His final words were long live Germany,
long live,
Austria,
long live Argentina.
These other countries with who I have been most closely associated and I shall
not forget them.
I had to obey the rules of my war.
Ends my flag.
I am ready.
I commend his body was cremated and disastrous scattered in international waters
in the Mediterranean Sea.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did,
there's a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday.
So hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to.
I need you.
But if you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do pit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.